welcome welcome yeah to this video did
we have bulova rocky start yet somehow
got a five minute game I was trying to
get a 15 minute one and it seems that I
also hit the five button right so we got
a modern defense against um the national
master do trio from Belgium and one of
those modern defenses were c4 and young
knight h6 intending Nigeria probably I
need to prevent this so question is how
to continue now you see able to play a
five maybe Queen d2 then f5
yeah i'm not sure i play some developing
first he can play Bishop age 6 haha
doesn't want to okay I need to open it
up here I don't want to play D 597 this
looks like Kings Indian with some extra
moves and I'd rather open up the
position here okay so let's grab here
and the 95 most most likely Bishop takes
aha
interesting
yeah maybe he intends to take on c3 at
some point it's possible plan
strengthening move theoretically you
could take on c3 and take you forward
this looks like looks weird c6
c6 this weekend's d6 by quite quite a
lot yeah okay let's grab some space
control the five square there were other
possibilities but this looks it looks
fine can't believe he would take oh I
didn't I didn't think about this move at
all it's a bit embarrassing okay yeah
well need to move the King now nothing
else it's probably not not terrible but
it wasn't what I had intended okay how
to continue and it's crap here
gain the space this was my plan would
therefore I only didn't anticipate that
my king would end up on on d 1 this is
this wasn't the plan okay if I go
Queenie one you would play Queen have
six probably I want to exchange this
this strong bishop strangely enough it
still looks like what what should you
ride yep otherwise I go on I deform yeah
the Sun still looks like i have some
space advantage and maybe a slider slide
pull the night on f7 is good at
defending d6 but otherwise it is not
doing much you see threatening something
I don't know don't think so very good
ice left quite good control in this
position
so maybe here make sure that you want is
covered
mmm 5 f-5 or something that I need to
consider bishop g 6 15 tags will be six
or p6 f5 check it doesn't eat too much
probably but i can i can try to get the
night to g3 and then intend to continue
here or should I just play now and I
need to play faster it first and
foremost I need to play faster
I might be able to play g5 but
check
going to go Bishop f5
yeah white is simply better in this
position questions how much maybe it's
it's not not so serious check when a bit
of time
check
I hope that this weekend is on h6 is a
problem for black can I take edge 6i can
take a for problem name
ok
cannot spend so much time
check
i can probably take it and play king
before three
check
check time learning
you
check
yeah just as just a dead wrong game
wrong yeah okay I'd certainly am better
in this position the question is so can
I cannot win with the the weakness on
age 6 I wonder about night h6 but
probably it's not working sometimes okay
this is the way to go now you can save
it I'm okay you had a salt soil together
this wouldn't work maybe before I have
some something better now I can always
play f5 but not sure what this is
actually accomplishing its killing my
own bishop yeah then oh yeah of course
what problem was that absolutely did see
tweenage for check otherwise I mean I
think what has a very comfortable
position i can i can just castle for
example and he's got a weakness on d6
it's it's not so easy for him to to get
a decent player with us okay thanks for
watching